with the year 2013 coming to a close I'm
the type of guy who always liked to
reflect on a year gone by and what a
year's been a one of the most beloved
political figure of our time passes away
North Korea declares their hatred
towards America in a shocking revelation
but exactly everyone already knew about
and for us geeks we've officially now
begun the next generation console war
where for the next eight years we get to
see gamers argue over which new
expensive black box they can more
effectively teabag their opponent in the
next Call of battlefield 9 while
elsewhere twerking in selfie become such
popular words that they were added to
the dictionary allegedly hope and
optimism were removed shortly afterwards
on the internet Harlem shake proved
right after Gangnam style that all you
need to do to start an internet
phenomenon is to effectively dance like
a [ __ ] and give his drop to video to ask
a question that apparently no one has
ever asked before a question so
intriguing that when asked it was met by
the sound of about six and a half
billion people around the world not
giving a [ __ ] but what was a year like
for anime what did 2013 say for us otaku
folk yes today only animes on I'm gonna
be looking back at the year 2013 - the
anime and moments that stood up for me
no I'm not going to be able to talk
about everything but I'll do my best to
cover everything that mattered to me so
with that intro out the way let's get
started we start at the beginning of the
year with the leftovers from the 2012
fall and winter seasons sword art online
had just recently ended before the start
of the year leaving everybody exhausted
from a spectacle of effectively watching
a show [ __ ] up itself during a
horrendous second half so it was kind of
a black hole period when it wasn't much
hype and nobody really knew what to
watch or follow even if there were some
legitimately good shows coming out do do
arm surprise the anime world by making
my Umar yuusha which apart from having a
name I can only pronounce correctly
every one in a hundred times was an
actual interesting and intellectual show
which was a step above the blood and
tits and elfin leave and the tits and
tips and acute ocean Queens blade and
full-on hentai that they were previously
famous for a series that showed him as
promised ruinous time was also Couture
asan
with one of the most emotionally
gripping beginning ten minutes I've ever
seen it tells the dark story of a young
innocent mine reader descending into
depression as she finds out her unique
power pushes everyone to hate her little
did we know that the first 10 minutes
was actually one of the biggest piece of
anime [ __ ]
in recent years and just becomes a
generic romance slice-of-life show like
everything else that's right the show
peaks in the first 10 minutes guys don't
get fooled don't whip your [ __ ] out lads
this girl does not put out in the
leftovers during the fall season shin
sekai europe resented a darkened story
different anime featuring humanity in a
dystopian society of flexing and
commenting on the issues of current
events perhaps one of the most acclaimed
series of 2013 which unfortunately went
largely unnoticed because oh my god as a
gay scene in episode a barking draw and
only garnered attention after completion
promoted by small but dedicated fanbase
last attempt has flipped the table and
conventional moral messages by making
trees the antagonist to the story yes
these bastard trees and the smug leaves
and them [ __ ] branches look at them
it sounds stupid but it did provide us
with a first full-on tree on tree fight
scene showing how dangerous trees can be
when I tried to take over the world I'm
watching you and Psychopaths showcase
get our booty being general og in a very
general [ __ ] written show morally and
because cop shows set an adult dystopian
feature with a main protagonist who
looks like she's firmly stoned with a
stand out and supposed to meet a stop
airing during this time was the grand
the extravagant the outlandish JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure
it never occurred to me why anyone would
want to adapt an old forgotten Shonen
manga but am I so glad that they did
it's over-the-top manliness campus and
ridiculous plot lines made for such an
entertaining wash that constantly asked
the question bro bro bro bro bro do you
even pose as stupid as I got at times it
wasn't most pure fine I had with a show
in 2013 and I highly recommend it for
anyone looking for a cool dumb action
series as the spring season emerged this
felt like the real start of anime in
2013 there were no more leftovers from
the year before and this was all a fresh
new start for anime that would set the
standard for the rest of the year and
what a way to start it
if there's one anime that will be
remembered for the year 2013 it's this
one yes this is the year that attack on
titan took the anime community by storm
starting a worldwide sensation that
became one of the most hyped anime ever
created there wasn't a single person in
the fandom running the least heard of
this show and for good reason the
fanboys would get pumped up for the
exhilarating action sequences and the
fangirls would gush over their captain
Levi most likely for his proven
housewife ability and that brooding look
he always had him himself like his
public trying to solve a rubix keep
using his mind it was a genuinely great
show in many aspects with an interesting
setting and a plot that really did take
you for a rollercoaster ride but it did
have its fair share of problems when it
came to the character departments and
also with the Titans themselves since
about halfway through the anime the
Titans went from these terrifying creepy
creatures to stupid looking humans going
to [ __ ] of course with pike not
everyone would love it but suffice to
say it deserved it spike way more than
some of the animes of previous years oh
and before I forget a quick mention of
the animes first opening that was it
alongside attack on Titan we had the
controversy that was our coup Nahanni
aka the flowers of evil yes this was an
experimental attempt to create a
psychological horror show using
rotoscope
animation that looks like they took a
human face got a toddler to replicate it
would play doh and then get someone with
arthritis to trace over it I kid I kid
it didn't look at that bad it had an
immersive plot with some legitimately
interesting ideas that played to the
uncanny valley effects but it was his
own worst enemy since the rotoscoping
looked on there is the bad at times that
it made it impossible to take seriously
highlights including this face that food
is that a man or a woman what is this
woman have a mustache Casca running so
stupidly that he apparently jumps
through time and my personal favorite
the unibrow of Nirvana on the topic of
nirvana Buddha seen here dodging rubber
bands in bullet time decided to descend
down from the heavens in springtime with
Jesus to live in an apartment block
together in the anime st. young men yes
this was a thing be sure to stay tuned
for season 2 you where Vishnu stars in a
more high school romance story with a la
sua say no gargantia tried to prove that
not everything written by general [ __ ]
has to be filtered with a sea of grain
depression even if it inevitably did in
the end while in valvrave The Liberator
audiences were treated to a rape scene
so unexpected
that the anime actually had to tell the
viewer that war was going on in this
scene here was in fact sex ten times
just in case we couldn't guess and then
we have or EE mo ah REE mo aka my little
sister can't be this cute this anime was
a light-hearted look at the otaku
culture that somewhere along the line
became waifu the anime but it was too
the fun show with some sincere
heartwarming moments that everyone could
get behind until the ending happened yes
the ending that most definitely has to
be talked about so if you do not want to
be spoiled then I suggest you click this
button right here to skip it the ending
finally answered the long-awaited
question of who our protagonist would
end up with and the answer we got was
their sister yes the show actually went
full incest on us and of course viewers
were torn apart with this development as
they realized that the title did exactly
as it said on the Tim the moment where
the mass public would turn tail and run
a [ __ ] mile the moment where
supporters of Korean echo and I say
collectively committed mass suicide
while the korean air train jumped for
joy as two seasons worth of ways he
culminated in one moment they watched on
endless repeat suffice said his ending
was controversial as hell but I can't
said I didn't enjoy the fan reaction
over it and I probably enjoyed this
anime way more than I should have
yes I know I don't know why either thank
you or mo for providing me with such
entertainment over the year and it's
ending worth talking about thank you for
the controversy you've created and for
trolling the entire fan base with your
ending goodbye yes esker neck oh so long
is a army you Taku Farnham have spoken
and final answer to the rest of the
world is that incest is most definitely
win cest see you in part 2